okay let's go on with the Twitter go -
problem I will stay with telling
Kentucky okay so remember the problem
was that you were out here I flew here
on the wrong here and then what happens
is when you turned in you're turning
them into that strike there and we're
still working with it as an ocular not
pinning okay not a disarming all right
so I cover on there all right I'm trying
to be here and let's just look at it
structured I was all the up on the
outside and I'm on the inside at some
point well they're like the marshal
necessity for going from the outside and
inside we have lots of techniques to
when we go from the inside the house
okay so it's not the answer isn't always
stay on the outside
every was the solution than the other
time okay that can't be I might want to
go to the inside alright so as we come
around I'm going to do the same thing
but I'm using the using this to get to
the inside do you guys understand that
okay everything will still apply so
don't focus on this on this out here and
you have no slack when you turning the
arm and then he goes how and then he
tries to unfurl himself that's not clear
today you have two factors
okay so whatever you're feeling is in
the center so even when I open it up I
should be not focusing on trying to get
that both I'm going to come in here this
way
imagine the strike coming around you're
going to do two strike
I'm going to move inside of it up I'm
moving inside here and I'm going to tap
the leg don't mind you just balance and
I come into the taco
make sure go to the stripes get in here
you know that's possible so you have to
get inside the shoulder okay so remember
low-percentage okay so don't we're not
asking a lot of the risks Brown I just
want this if you come around here and
you try to crank this thing people are
strong can't you're not going to get it
I don't wanna die right so I'm looking
at getting away from that one
[Music]
okay if you pay attention there's not
really much listed into it it's in the
elbow shoulder take out the base okay
what I'm seeing is you're like get the
rest and you didn't keep moving okay
you
okay so you still need your serenity
Dexter
you can't you Kevin in all of this
creates laugh when you're just out here
at the wrist there's a lot of slack
though that's why it's still I still
live in in his body
I'm in his body in his body his body in
his body
his body in his body that would be the
first drug I remember I didn't go there
for no reason there was some reason why
I went to the inside watch how I'm
always hiding from this arm
[Music]
you
okay the version we want to do is I'm
always on the back of that always on the
bow okay always here so when I go to
turn you see I go to return to Nate got
the leg the punch actually it goes
around my head but it's very common to
go okay I'll be behind them
I'll be behind him now I start one like
that you see and now I mean this 180
which is what most people do on the ten
o'clock there it is again
so you have to watch how your GEB and I
think the best thing to do is to have a
feeling of Heidi Heidi okay all right
going from the outside to the inside out
of ignorance
there was a Marshall reason why maybe I
need their body right between me and
another friend or maybe I want him under
me you can see could go right to a penny
technique from them okay there's some
reason for it so again there's plenty
good reasons why
plenty of reasons okay
that's what we're doing so this time and
but every time I do it I have to be
aware of the cross bottom arm so this
time my word this is one that I'm going
to talk it before it attacks me okay so
as I come around and I go in I'm
attacking it at this angle here so from
where I got boom to the elbow so I was
hiding hiding and then I'm going here
make sure that your angle basically hit
on the outside of whatever is coming you
see right so you have to come from here
straight if there's something there like
you did the other take note the other
technique you see there's nothing there
I can take the head I can take the leg
and go to the first one
so you strikes coming my ketchup the
bottom part for the savings glassmaking
oh this is all the same there it is
you